what's up you guys time once again for
flickers of fear and here we are again
in folk horror february i've been taking
advantage of uh shutter who just added a
whole bunch of folk horror movies they
had some on there previously as well but
because of the documentary that came out
which i've talked about on a few other
videos which is called woodlands dark
and days bewitched which is kind of like
a comprehensive folk horror documentary
about three hours and 15 minutes long
and it's excellent
and uh since they added that to shutter
they also added a selection of
folk horror films from you know the 60s
to the present day i believe there's
between 45 and 50 different folk horror
movies on there so if you don't have
shutter yet i mean you definitely should
um you know it's it's just a great
service i like it a lot i'm not
sponsored by them or anything like that
although it'd be nice but uh yeah i just
think it's really a good value for the
money and they're always adding new
stuff they add new stuff every week old
stuff new stuff classics uh originals
everything
so as i said this whole month we're
gonna do folk horror movies and this
movie right here uh which is also on
shutter i believe the first time i
watched it because i've seen it two or
three times the first time i watched it
i think it was on netflix although i
don't believe it's on netflix anymore i
watched it back in probably 2017 2018
and i really really liked it and because
you know much like when i talked about
the whaling uh it was one that i saw
around the same time period and since i
was doing folk horror i decided i would
do this one as well just in case uh you
know people hadn't seen it
so and i definitely wanted to
give it some love
so this is a movie called a dark song it
came out in 2016 although i believe it
wasn't released in the us until 2017
like on streaming services and stuff
like that this is an irish film
and was actually the debut film of a guy
named liam gavin
i don't know if he's made any sense then
but the fact that this was his first one
i'm always like so impressed when that
happens like it was kind of the same
thing that happened with like ariasser
when like hereditary came out and you
know he's like hey this is my first
movie just like blew everything away uh
yeah so
i'm very very impressed when people's
first feature film is this good
now i will say this movie okay if you're
really into
occult stuff and i mean occult stuff
like in the old school
uh like grimoire aleister crowley
that kind of thing like the whole ritual
aspect of it then you will really really
dig this it is you know i know it's a
cliche to say it's like a slow burn i
definitely do like those
it's a very
contained movie there's really only two
characters uh it takes place in one
location more or less there's a couple
scenes at the beginning that are outside
of that but pretty much the whole thing
takes place in this remote like filthy
farmhouse and
pretty much the end all of the horror
comes from
the
sort of like escalating tension between
the two characters and
your uncertainty about what exactly is
going to happen uh so it's kind of like
the first two acts are mostly i want to
say it's like almost like psychological
horror just these kind of like two
characters interacting and they're both
really interesting characters so i think
that really carries it along but then
like the third act goes way more like
supernatural so
you know there is a lot of like creepy
horror elements toward the end because
it does kind of go crazy but up until
then it's almost like i want to say it's
almost like a stage play not exactly i
don't know if i want to say that or not
but just in the sense that it's
basically just like two characters
interacting over a prolonged period of
time
so
the setup of the movie
there's this woman named sophia
and at the beginning she's
renting this house
out in this this really like remote old
creepy
terrible house like with no heating and
all this other stuff out in uh north
wales like in the countryside somewhere
so she pays for like a year in advance
and then gives the estate agent like
extra money for privacy she says so she
rents it a year in advance uh and that's
what she's doing you don't know entirely
why at first
so then she goes and interviews this guy
joseph solomon who's played by steve
oram who usually i think he normally
does comedy i think he's been in a
couple of
other horror movies i kind of want to i
thought that he was in
the canal maybe
i don't think it was a huge part but i
thought i remembered seeing him in that
please correct me if i'm wrong um but
he's like you know him and katherine
walker who plays sofia are basically the
only two characters other than a couple
glimpses like of other people at the
beginning
so she's interviewing this guy joseph
solomon
now he is an occultist
she has apparently gone to
because you know i guess
i guess people that do like occult
rituals and stuff like in the in the
modern day it's probably like you know
kind of a kind of a small scene i'd
imagine so she kind of lists off she's
like i went to this guy i went to that
guy i went to this guy none of them
wanted to help me look i have 80 000
pounds i want you to do this ritual for
me
now joseph or mr solomon as he insists
on being called
is
not a pleasant individual uh he's a
little bit uh abrasive let's call it
that kind of bullying kind of a dick
it's interesting because i saw like a
little clip of an interview with steve
aurum that said he was actually really
interested to play this role because
he's like usually you know in a horror
movie or any kind of of movie really
when you have somebody that's playing an
occultist he's like normally you would
have kind of like an old wizard type
dude or you would have kind of like a
younger suave like magician type dude he
liked that this movie has as the
occultist essentially he said just a
working-class bloke
uh and it was indeed a very interesting
choice i don't think i've ever seen any
other movie that just had a regular
schlub like as an occultist but he does
know his [ __ ] but he again very very
abrasive very unpleasant
so basically sophia tells him look it's
like i rented this house you gave me all
these specifications she rented this
house it's it's kind of like based a
little bit on um it's based on actual
occult right uh the abermelon there's
some stuff that's in there that's not
super accurate like blood drinking and
stuff
but i was actually watching a video
earlier by a dude who i guess was like a
professor of like you know occult
studies or whatever and he was talking
about this movie and he was kind of
pointing out where was like well that's
not like the abermellon but he's like
other than that this is one of the most
accurate portrayals
of a magical ritual of this type that's
ever been you know put to film so he's
like obviously liam gavin the director
who also wrote it
uh did do his homework on this like big
time so it's kind of based on if you're
really into like aleister crowley and
all the [ __ ] that he was doing at
bellescan house and stuff like that this
is very much inspired by that uh so yeah
so she says okay well you know you told
me we needed a house with you know this
room had to be facing west and all this
other kind of stuff it had to be really
isolated and she's like so i did that i
rented it for a year and at first he
doesn't really want to do it
now
he comes and looks at the house and he's
like yeah whatever the house is fine the
reason that he doesn't really want to do
it at first is because uh spoiler alert
she is kind of a lied to him a little
bit about why she wants to do it
at first he's like basically this ritual
will summon your guardian angel
uh and maybe some other things too there
might be some demons is very very
dangerous uh so he does let her know
that up front
she wants to summon her guardian angel
she tells him at first because she's
like i love someone and they don't love
me back so it's almost kind of like she
wants to do a love spell he thinks this
is lame um
you know and he's just kind of like
crabby about it he's like look just i
came out here and looked at the house i
don't want to do it um you know just
give me the money and i'll just you know
piss off or whatever
but then finally she comes clean to him
and she says no actually uh you know
because he's gonna leave like she takes
him to the train station and then she
says okay i lied actually what i wanted
to do was um i want to ask my guardian
angel
if i can speak to my dead son
she had a son who was seven years old
and he was apparently kidnapped and
murdered and she wants to talk to him
she says so joseph's like why didn't you
tell me that to start with and she was
like well i just thought it would be too
much i thought it'd be much easier to
say and he's like look uh you know this
is heavy [ __ ] that we're dealing with
you know angels demons all of that kind
of stuff um he's like you know your
soul's on the line he's like you really
have to be honest with me
so now that that's all out in the open
they go to the house and proceed uh with
the ritual now as i said once they go to
the house they do not leave pretty much
uh so basically the whole entire movie
is them
doing this ritual and i know that maybe
when i just say it like that it sounds
kind of boring but it's totally totally
not it's like really really compelling
and i think a lot of it is because of
the character work and i really like the
interaction between these two
i like that neither one of them are
particularly
i don't want to say they're unlikable
they're but they're uh real flawed
people joseph solomon is particularly
unlikable at first
but as it goes on he does do some pretty
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
um you know that's pretty unforgivable
but
he does show another side of himself
that maybe he's not just this terrible
like
you know grouchy ass
bullying person
uh
sophia obviously because she's a
grieving mother and she's willing to go
to these lengths to do this
rigorous you know kind of ritual which
i'll explain in a minute
that she's willing to do that to talk to
her dead son once again so obviously
you're gonna have sympathy for her there
but
she's not entirely honest either like
she has some other ulterior motives in
there that she doesn't really tell him
at first which again so that kind of
makes her unlikable and also the fact
that he
you know as as abrasive as he is he does
tell her look we have to do this that
and the other thing are you ready to do
that as unpleasant as it is she says
that she is but then sometimes when it
actually when push comes to shove she
does actually like complain about it so
like i said that does kind of make her a
little bit more unlikable but
unlikable doesn't mean
uh that you don't want to watch them
because these two characters are very
very very compelling and the
relationship they have between them
so this ritual the abermelon
it basically concerns i mean he goes
around the house and you know draws all
the chalk circles and all the symbols
and everything like that and all these
different rooms and he goes and explains
what each room signifies and all these
other things now prior to them going to
this house because he says once we close
ourselves into this house because he
does the whole salt ring around the
house and everything like that once i
close off this salt ring we cannot leave
and this uh ritual may take a year
now prior to
them even going to the house
sophia has uh abstained from
from sex uh even masturbation she has um
abstained from alcohol for the prior six
months so she's been like purifying
herself even before they go to the house
and like seal themselves in so basically
she buys like a year's worth of supplies
and she is ready
to close herself in with
essentially a total stranger to do
this ritual to contact her son or at
least that's what
she says at first i don't necessarily
want to spoil everything about this
because there are like some revelations
like i said she's not completely honest
about what her intentions are but you
know that comes to light later on so he
seals the house up and now they're both
in this house for the long haul he's
like literally we cannot leave until
this ritual is completed or all kind of
terrible [ __ ] will take place so over
the course of the movie you see it just
keeps ramping up and ramping up the [ __ ]
that she has to do like basically it's
kind of like and as i said it's pretty
fairly accurate to the actual ritual
in the sense that you're trying to
sort of take yourself to your physical
limits like for example
she has to uh sit in this circle for
like three days you know what i mean she
can't eat she can't sleep she can't go
to the bathroom she just has to sit
there and not move and like contemplate
this rock uh she has to copy and recopy
like all of these symbols and all of
these kind of incantations and all this
other stuff and uh basically there's a
couple things that she doesn't want to
do um she has a problem with forgiveness
which is one of the big um themes of the
film
and
because she won't do this one
forgiveness ritual she's like no
absolutely not he's like okay well then
we have to work around it meaning you
are going to have to drink my blood uh
which she really doesn't want to do but
you know so she has to do like all these
physical purges she said like these
mushrooms that like clean her all out so
she's like puking and everything and so
you know and uh obviously mr solomon
joseph is you know just he's the one
that knows everything so he's like
bossing her around you know she
oversleeps one day and he throws buckets
of cold water on her um and he does like
all these you know he's just constantly
like yelling at her and they're just
constantly at each other's throats
although
as it goes on
they do kind of i don't know if they
come become friends necessarily but
they do kind of develop a mutual respect
i guess and you know more of a
protective type of thing although you
never get the sense that
i don't know i don't know if that's fair
to say i don't know if you you never
really get the sense that he cares all
that much like whether she's able to
contact her son or not but you know it's
it's kind of like it's a very very
strange like relationship and there is
actually one point in there where he
does something
really kind of [ __ ] up because at the
beginning of the ritual like before they
seal themselves in um he's basically
like well we might have to do like sex
magic you know meaning you have to have
sex with me and he and she and he's like
you know are you willing to do that and
she says yeah
and then at one point that comes up
but then
i don't necessarily want to spoil it but
but then he's just kind of like oh well
we didn't we didn't even have to do that
for the ritual i just you know what i
mean so it was that kind of thing and
she was like you piece of [ __ ] and then
like she pees in his oatmeal or whatever
but so yeah it's a very contentious
relationship
now as the time goes on and as i said
the the ritual does take a very long
time like the seasons are passing
outside a few times because she messed
up or she lied about something like
sometimes they have to go back and like
start things over
now at first
little things happen in the house
because she keeps asking him how you
know how do we know that it's starting
to work
and
like little things will happen like a
bird hit the window like you know what i
mean like smacked into the window and
died and he's like look that's a sign
he's like so it's [ __ ] like that which
could be
nothing
so for a long time and the first time i
watched this like for a long time i was
sitting there thinking is that guy just
like full of [ __ ] and this is just hi
the way he gets his jollies is just by
pretending that he knows all this stuff
and then like ordering women around like
in this isolated house and they can't
leave and like he has them under his
power it's like does he actually know
what he's talking about is he is
anything actually gonna happen or is he
just full of crap because for a long
time
little things will happen like oh
there's a thump under the floor or like
i said the bird hitting the window uh
you know little things like that are
there these little flowers like
scattered in the hallway that weren't
there before and they can't figure out
where they came from so it's just like
little plausible deniability [ __ ]
so
she's kind of like okay well that means
and he keeps saying no that means
something that means it's working and
she's kind of like i don't think this is
working i just you know i think you're
full of crap but then like as the movie
goes on
the supernatural stuff starts to get
more and more
uh you know undeniable
uh this does have kind of like i said i
don't want to say it's a crazy ending
but
it's
considering how subdued the
movie was up to that point the end i was
just kind of like wow
all right i kind of like it though it
was like pretty awesome i was not
expecting it because it goes big you
know what i mean and that's all i'm
gonna say considering as i said how
subdued it was up to that point so i
thought that was like a really ballsy
like ending and i thought it was kind of
cool some people i i was reading the
reviews on shutter
and most people really love this movie
it has like 91 or something like that on
rotten tomatoes and on some of the other
uh you know services the you know rating
services
but some people didn't like the end
because they thought it was
i don't know i think some somebody said
well they thought it was lamb or that or
the implication of it was lame i didn't
think that at all um i actually thought
it was a really good ending and it tied
everything together thematically so
you know and but like i said i like that
that it went like kind of ballsy and
then also yeah it's a it's a audacious
ending i'll say that
but prior to that there's just like
really really cool i love like the slow
ramp up of just this creepy [ __ ] because
like i said at first
he keeps saying yeah the ritual's
working but she doesn't buy it at first
because it's just kind of this stuff
that maybe could be supernatural but
maybe could be totally
nothing
but then as it goes on she starts for
example like hearing
her son's voice like talking to her from
like behind this closed door and it's
like really really creepy like she knows
it's not really him that it's like some
demon that's true that's impersonating
him to try to get her to
you know do whatever is trying to get
her to open the door but that's super
creepy and like one time she's
in this room like the study and she's
writing her incantations and she looks
up and there's just this black
figure like a shadow just sitting there
in the chair like and all you can see is
like it's cigarette like at the end and
it's like so so creepy and it's just
like but little [ __ ] like that but then
at the end it just goes like whole hog
but you know like i said if you're
really into i don't think i've ever seen
a movie
that
basically took
an actual or you know as close as i've
ever seen in film an actual
magical ritual
and
put it to film in this way and kind of
showed you that people that were into
the occult you know whether it was
aleister crowley or whatever like prior
to that like what it was they were
trying to do and i like too that it's
not
it doesn't make magic look evil you know
what i'm saying it's kind of like
just showing it is like another way to
knowledge or enlightenment
and
you know yeah there's some like some bad
[ __ ] could happen if you [ __ ] around
with it or you don't do it right but
it doesn't portray it in a negative
light like it doesn't portray it as
anything satanic or anything like that
it's just like kind of neutral but you
know
however it is that you use it so i like
that they did that and i really like
the fact that they showed like the
mechanics
of this ritual and how difficult it
would be
how difficult it is
and how
desperate you would have to be
to
you know
to get what you wanted out of this
ritual that you would be willing to seal
yourself into a house
in the middle of nowhere for a year with
a a very unpleasant man who you don't
really know
and subjecting yourself to
you know all kind of really really
physically taxing uh mentally taxing you
know things just to get to this one
particular point and i really i really
really like that because i feel like
that's very very unexplored particularly
in horror movies
but yeah if you're into occult stuff as
i said that's almost kind of like a play
it's really only two characters i think
that
toward the beginning of the movie like
before
uh before sophia goes to the house she
actually like has a conversation with
her sister
like in a restaurant or something and
she's talking about what she's gonna do
and
uh you know that gives you some
exposition about why she's so desperate
to do it because she talks about her son
being dead
and so you know but other than that i
think that's pretty much it like until
you get to the end and there's like
demons and stuff that's pretty much the
only time you see another person so this
is a very very
it's not even claustrophobic i don't
think i didn't find it particularly
claustrophobic but it is you know very
it's very very isolated it's just these
two people's
interactions with each other doing this
really
rigorous like strenuous
thing and like not knowing whether it's
gonna work or not you know what i mean
and it's just like i don't know and the
cinematography is gorgeous uh i love the
score and the sound design of this i
have to point that out as well excellent
uh i really really liked all the all the
score and everything for this too but
yeah the the all the shots of
the welsh countryside and stuff like
that just gorgeous um you know i spent
quite a bit of time in wales not north
wales i actually was in south wales but
you know it looks very very similar and
you know just these kind of like distant
rolling hills and it's like really
really beautiful but yeah this is
definitely definitely a really really
cool folk horror movie if you're into a
cult stuff um and if you're into kind of
more creepy
slow burn type of stuff then you should
definitely check this out if you haven't
seen it as i said i watched it on
shutter it used to be on netflix but i
don't think it is anymore at least not
in the united states but i'm sure you
can probably find it on some other
streaming services if you don't have
shutter but if you've seen it let me
know what you thought about it in the
comments and that will do it for this
flickers of fear continuing with folk
horror february and i will see you guys
on the next one
bye